I've titled tonight's lecture in the
mists of time. And that's a nice sort of
misty background over there.
The mists of time is a lecture on Daniel
chapter 2.
I am God and there is none like me
declaring the end from the beginning and
from ancient times the things that are
not yet done. Isaiah 46 chapters verses
9 and 10. So God says, "I will tell you
ahead of time what will happen from the
beginning right until the end of time."
And in Daniel, we have a key to the book
of Revelation. In fact, the two books
Daniel and Revelation go hand in hand.
The symbolism that we find in the book
of Revelation
is actually borrowed from the whole of
the Bible, but the images are borrowed
from the book of Daniel specifically.
Jesus says in Matthew 24
when he was questioned about the signs
of the end that we should study the book
of Daniel in particular. It states that
in Matthew 24 and of course in the book
of Revelation it also says blessed are
they who read
and take to heart what is written in
this prophecy. So the end time books,
those that have the sweep through
history telling us the events as they
will unfold will be found in these great
books of the Bible. So God declares, "I
am God and there is none like me
declaring the end from the beginning and
from ancient times the things that are
not yet done. Either this is so or this
is not so." Now there are many symbolic
symbols used in the Bible and we can get
very confused if we don't apply the
right principles to what we are
listening to. You have to apply biblical
criteria in order to understand Bible
prophecy. We cannot just take a symbol
out of the air. For example, the Bible
speaks about a beast. In Revelation, it
talks about a beast. It talks about a
mark of a beast. It talks about
something that must be put into the hand
and into the forest and this represents
the mark of the beast for example. Well,
what is the beast? You can do anything
with that word beast. You could say like
many in the world say today, the beast
is a computer. Some say even which one?
They say it is a computer in Brussels.
Well, does the Bible say beasts are
computers? Yes or no? You have to stick
to biblical criteria. The Bible uses
symbols of animals. It uses, for
example, lions and bears and things like
that. Now, there are sports teams that
are known as the lions. The British
Isles rugby football team is known as
the Lions. So, am I to read into the
Bible that the British rugby football
team is going to play an important part
at the end of time just because it says
the Lions or the Bears? That's another
sporting team. Is that going to be a
criterium? Of course not. We have to use
biblical criteria in order to deal with
biblical things. So, I've put together a
little dictionary here of prophetic
terms where they are defined in the
Bible. And we have to use the Bible
definitions. For example, white linen is
righteousness. Revelation 19:8.
The white linen you saw represents the
righteousness of the saints.
A trumpet or a wind or symbols of war in
the Bible. Revelation 49:36.
That is now in a prophetic sense.
Prostitution. I wonder how many sermons
have been preached about lentious women
and prostitution and all of these
things. When in actual fact, God uses
the word prostitute in a prophetic sense
to refer to idolatry, being unfaithful
to God. And there are just numerous
texts that are listed here which show
that idolatry is prostitution. God even
had a cryptic lesson for Israel. He even
had a prophet of his marry a prostitute
to give an object lesson of the
unfaithfulness of the people of Israel
towards their God.
Water or sea in the Bible represents
nations when it's in a prophetic sense.
The waters you saw are peoples and
nations and multitudes and kings.
Revelation 17:E5,
a woman in the Bible is a church.
Ephesians 5:22 to to 24, 2 Corinthians,
Jeremiah, Isaiah, Hosea, John, all of
them refer to the symbolism of a woman
representing the church. Christ is the
bridegroom. The church is his bride.
Zion is a symbol of God's people. Isaiah
51:16. And a beast in the Bible in a
prophetic sense is a kingdom. Daniel 7
verse1 17 says, "And the beasts which
you saw are kingdoms or kings." And a
king stands for a kingdom. So it's not a
football team and it's not a computer.
It's a kingdom. That's it.
So if someone has a mark of the beast
then it is a mark of a kingdom.
That's what it means. Cannot mean
anything else. We have to stay with the
Bible. A horn in the Bible also
represents a king or a kingdom.
So out of a kingdom can arise a number
of horns. That means the kingdom will
disintegrate and many kingdoms will
arise out of that kingdom.
A rock in the Bible, the rock in the
Bible is Jesus. That's what we sang in
our theme song. Now, there's a war
between good and evil on this planet.
And if someone doesn't want to believe
that, switch on your television and have
a look and you will see that there's a
war between good and evil. There's a war
over every single soul on this planet
whether we want to acknowledge it or
whether we don't. Now a very interesting
little key story in the Bible is Daniel
chapter 2 where King Nebuchadnezzar has
a dream
and in this dream he dreams of certain
events which shall unfold but he forgets
the dream and then he is very confused
and the prophet eventually unfolds the
dream for him. And in this dream we can
pick up some very interesting
road signs
of history and time. Now Nebuchadnezzar
also known as Nabu Kuri Usur was the
founder of the great Babylon. The
original founder of Babylon was of
course Nimrod and then it had a period
of greatness under Hamurabi and then
Nebuchadnezzar
built it up to the glory of the
Calaldanss, the greatest city that ever
existed on the face of the planet. So
Nebuchadnezzar was very very proud of
his achievements.
Jerusalem was destroyed by
Nebuchadnezzar in 586 BC. And during
this time, captives were taken to
Babylon. And amongst them were, of
course, the Hebrew faithful such as
Daniel and his friends. And here we see
a relief of the captives actually being
taken to Babylon as slaves. Many of them
when they were caught they were made
unox
but well to be for the rest of their
lives never to have the honor or the
pleasure of having children. So there
were terrible times in those days.
These young men according to the
biblical story were then enrolled in the
institutes of higher learning. They went
to the university and they studied the
language and they studied the wisdom of
the calaldanss.
Babylu is the site of Nebuchadnezzar's
summer palace. Here it is for example.
And the word babel has a very
interesting com connotation.
Bab lub is a gate, a portal and l is
god. So the word babl babel means a
portal to god.
Now the bible says there is someone else
who calls himself the door and that is
Jesus Christ. He says I am the door. So
Jesus is actually saying I am the barb
the gate through which one must enter
into the kingdom of heaven. Jesus says I
am the door and nobody comes to the
father except
>> through me. So that is the door the
entryway into heaven. Bub L represents
another entryway, another door whereby
you try to climb into heaven by another
way, another door. Above Elu is then
also a portal. The king was divine in
the old days, although the Babylonian
and Assyrian kings did not go that far.
They were high priests generally. So in
Daniel chapter 2 we read now in the
second year of Nebuchadnezzar's reign
Nebuchadnezzar had dreams. Now here we
have a problem immediately we have a
problem and the higher critics have such
fun with verses such as these. You see a
little bit of knowledge is a dangerous
thing. So the higher critics complained
about this text because it says in the
second year of Nebuchadnezzar's reign
but then a little bit further on it says
in the third year of Daniel's captivity
and Daniel had completed three years of
study when this took place and
Nebuchadnezzar and these captives
started off at the same time. So they
were saying well how's this possible?
Nebuchadnezzar is in his second year and
the others are in their third year. The
Bible is pathetic.
Makes simple mistakes like that. But
then of course they didn't realize that
the two systems, the Hebrew system of
counting was totally different to the
Babylonian system. When a Babylonian
king ascended to the throne, his first
year was not counted. It was known as
the year of ascension.
So the second year of his reign would be
the third year according to the
Babylonian system. And God does not
acknowledge it when he speaks about his
Hebrew worthies. He sticks to his system
where any part of a year was considered
as a completeness. Any part of a day was
considered as a completeness. That
explains many things. For example, the
crucifixion. Three days. Three days. And
anybody who wants to work it out will
say, "Now, hang on a second. If he Jesus
died on Friday towards sunset and he
stayed in the grave during the Sabbath
and he rose on the first day of the
week, that doesn't make three days in
our reckoning today. But in the Hebrew
mindset, which is inclusive reckoning,
it does because any part of the day will
count as day one. So because it was
before sunset on Friday, that's day one.
And it was a complete day in the grave,
that's day two. And any portion of the
day on the third day is day three. So
that is in the biblical record three
days, three evening mornings, three days
nights. So no anomaly here just
reckoning according to the right systems
and his spirit was so troubled that his
sleep left him. So the king summoned the
magicians, the enchanters, the sorcerers
and the astrologers to tell him what he
had dreamed. And when they came in and
stood before the king, he said to them,
now you know in our modern times, we
believe how primitive. Here the man has
a dream and he summons the enchanters
and the sorcerers and the astrologers to
tell him what he had dreamed. Now that's
what kings in ancient days did. They
were surrounded by these wise insider
knowledgeable ones. And each one of
these categories had a certain function.
The enchanter would throw the charms and
find out. The sorcerer would be a deep
occultist who would use occult
communications to find out. The
astrologers would look at the stars to
tell him what he had to do.
Is it such an ancient custom or is it
alive and well and living today in our
century? Yes or no? Do presidents of the
United States make use of this system?
Yes or no? Ronald Rean didn't do a move
without consulting all of these
categories.
And Nelson Mandela in southern Africa
will not make a move without having his
some gormas come and throw the bones.
And the astrologologists tell him what
to do. And the kings of Europe are no
different. They are occultists in that
sense. You can just study what the
kingdoms do and what the kings and
queens of England do, for example, and
how they communicate with the spirit
world in order to find out what they
should do. Does not Prince Charles
consult Mount Baton who is already dead
when he has something important to do?
Well, nothing has changed. Don't think
that this is an ancient custom. This is
a present day custom very much so. And
the analogy tells us that things have
not really changed. So all of these wise
people came to the king and he said to
them, "I have had a dream that troubles
me and I want to know what it means."
Daniel 2 1-3 the NIV the King James
actually says this thing has gone from
me
which means I cannot remember it I
cannot remember it but I know it was
vitally important so please if you
really are what you say then you must
tell me what this means the king
answered and said to the calaldian this
thing is gone from me
if you will not make known known unto me
the dream with the interpretation
thereof. You shall be cut in pieces and
your houses shall be made a dung hill.
Ancient kings had much power. When a
king spoke, that was it. You remember
the book of Esther. If the king did not
hold out his staff to whoever came in,
that person was dead. He was dead. He
was killed on the spot. He was taken out
and executed if the king didn't give him
the right to enter and to speak.
Verse 10 says, "The Calaldanss." Now,
who are the Calaldanss? The Calaldanss
are the learned ones. Those are the
highly educated ones, the astronomers,
the brilliant ones. And we have
Calaldanss today.
Some religious orders concentrate their
most intellectual,
most educated people in the world
into certain orders which actually run
many of our universities. And the very
top universities in the world, the
highest universities that we have in the
world today are run by categories of
people that today would be the exact
equivalent of the Calaldanss. Nothing
has changed. So these are the educated
ones answered before the king and said,
"There is not a man upon the earth that
can show the king's matter. Therefore,
there is no king, lord, nor ruler that
asks such a thing. And any magician or
astrologer or calaldian
see the different categories all of them
were not able to do this. It is a rare
thing that the king requireth and there
is none other that can show it before
the king except the gods whose dwelling
is not with flesh. So God actually
removed this thing from this king's mind
so that he would not be able to just
recall it and also to expose all of
these categories of people.
Verse 12, for this cause the king was
angry and very furious and commanded to
destroy all the wise men of Babylon.
All. Now obviously that included all of
those that had received this higher
learning which would then have included
Daniel and his friends because they had
completed their education at the
Babylonian Institute of Higher Learning.
So all of them were sentenced to death
on one day just because they could not
answer the dream. When Daniel heard that
they were all going to be put to death,
he went to Ariel, the king's guard, and
said, "Is there any way that I could
speak to the king?"
And after he had given permission,
Daniel returned to his house and
explained the matter to his friends,
Haniah, Mika, and Azaria, Mishael. Very
interesting names here. Actually, we
haven't got time to go into all the
details, but there's even a typology in
the name of events as they will unfold.
Daniel means judgment, people of
judgment. Mael, the one who is what God
is. Very interesting analogies there.
Daniel 2:17 and 18, he urged them to
plead for mercy from the God of heaven
concerning this mystery so that he and
his friends might not be executed with
the rest of the wise men of Babylon.
That's the basic story behind the story.
In Daniel 2,
we have this statement. And he God
changes the times and the seasons. He
removes kings and sets up kings. So,
it's going to be a story of how kingdoms
will arise and kingdoms will disappear
on this planet.
Daniel 2:4 tells us of how the king is
then informed that Daniel actually has
an answer. Do not execute the wise men
of Babylon. Take me to the king and I
will interpret his dream for him. See,
God in night vision gave Daniel not only
a description of the dream but also the
solution to the dream. The king asked
Daniel also called the Basar which is of
course uh his name given to him in place
of Daniel judgment. So the whole book of
Daniel is about judgment. It's about the
final judgment of this planet and the
judgment of the various kingdoms as we
go along. Belle, Sasa, Bell was the god
of the Calaldanss. Bell, we'll deal a
lot with this god bell. And uh he's very
much in vogue today. There are many many
many organizations that name themselves
after Bell to this very day.
also called Balsasa. Are you able to
tell me what I saw in my dream and
interpret it? Daniel 2:26. Did Daniel
say, "Yes, I can." Yes, I can. No, he
didn't.
Belasa,
Bel goddess,
shour
to protect. So, Bell is a male deity.
Bellot is a female deity. whether they
were male or female, they were
interchangeable. That's an interesting
uh thought. We will go into that in
greater detail in the future. Daniel
answered in the presence of the king and
said, "The secret which the king has
demanded cannot the wise men, the
astrologers, the magicians, the
soothsayers."
It's fascinating to me that every single
one of these categories exists today and
is being used by the world today and by
the leadership of the world today. But
there is a God in heaven that revealth
secrets and maketh known to the king
Nebuchadnezzar what shall be in the when
latter days. Daniel 2:2728.
So Daniel chapter 2 is a book for our
time. It's for our time. It gives
something for all ages. But the climax
of history, the Daniel, the judgment,
the final judgment comes in our time.
Isn't it surprising that people say,
"Cut the Old Testament off. We don't
need it anymore."
Well, Jesus said, "When you see these
things, when you see the abomination
that causes desolation standing here,
then let the reader of Daniel
understand." Speaking about the future,
Jesus himself points to Daniel and it
concerns our time. And he doesn't take
the credit. He gives the credit to God.
You see, there are two religious systems
on this planet. The one system is man
centered and the other is God centered
and that is the battle for every
person's soul on this planet and you
will be surprised who today advocates a
man centered religion you will be
surprised I'll put them up on the screen
one after the other for you as we go on
Daniel 2:29
as You were lying there, O king, your
mind turned to things to come. And the
revealer of mysteries showed you what is
going to happen.
And this is basically what he dreamed.
He saw a statue
with a head of gold,
silver arms and chest, bronze.
And this head of gold was very
magnificent.
Two arms, hips of bronze,
legs of iron, two legs, and then feet of
iron and clay.
And then he saw a rock hurtle towards
earth,
strike the statue, and destroy it.
and it struck at the feet. Nowhere else
it struck at the feet. Well, what does
this dream mean? Well, the Bible is so
kind as to tell us exactly what it
means. So, we don't even have to guess.
You looked, oh king, and there before
you stood a large statue, an enormous,
dazzling statue, awesome in appearance.
That's what he dreamt.
And you saw this rock come. Daniel 2:es
32-33.
The head of the statue was made of pure
gold. Its chest and arms of silver, its
belly and thighs of bronze, its legs of
iron, its feet partly of iron and partly
of baked clay.
So, it was a look into the future and it
also concerned the last days. While you
were watching, a rock was cut out.
Notice carefully.
But not by human hands.
So this intervention is not a human
intervention. But what kind of an
intervention?
It's a divine intervention.
It struck the statue on its feet. Please
be very careful.
It does not strike the statue on the
hips. Are you with me?
hips. Now, why would I emphasize that?
Is that important? Yes, it happens to be
important because whole religious
systems in the world out there have the
statue strike the hips.
When the statue is not struck at the
hips, the rock strikes the feet. The
rock does not strike the hips.
So already just with this simple
analogy,
half of the religious world out there,
Christian religious world has something
wrong. Seriously wrong. All right,
that's what the Bible says. Check it out
for yourself. It struck the statue on
its feet of iron and clay and smashed
them. Daniel 2:34.
So who is this rock? Obviously, if it's
not a human intervention, it's a divine
intervention.
So if you are expecting some aid from
some superpower,
whichever that superpower may be, I have
news for you. The final intervention is
a divine intervention.
It is the second coming of Christ. Then
notice the iron,
the clay, the bronze, the silver, the
gold were broken to pieces. Now hang on
a second.
If this statue is sequential,
why when you strike the feet is the
iron, that's the legs, the clay, that's
the feet and the iron. The bronze,
that's the hips. The silver, that's the
chest, and the gold broke into pieces at
the same time
and became like chuff and a threshing
floor in the summer. Why is the whole
lot destroyed when it strikes the feet?
You see, if these kingdoms would occur
one after the other, then does this make
any sense? Yes, it does. But only if
the philosophy of the head
advanced and built out in the philosophy
of the chest increased greatly in the
philosophy of the hips and incorporated
into the philosophy of the iron and
disseminated to the world in the
philosophy of the iron and clay. When
that philosophy is finally destroyed,
all of history's contribution to the
kingdom of the other party, the enemy of
God, come to an end. Everything. Do we
today teach Babylonian philosophy?
Yes, we do. Yes, we do. I have a lecture
called the wine of Babylon. You will be
stunned how much Babylonian philosophy
we teach. Do we teach Meo Persian
philosophy?
Absolutely we do. Is the religion of
mitism alive and well and living in the
world today? Yes. The greatest religious
power in the world, the most powerful
religious power in the world teaches
Mitraism.
Very interesting. That's Meo Persian. Do
we have Greek philosophy in the world
today? Absolutely. Where's the where
does the theory of evolution come from?
It started with Aristotle. Where do our
modern and where does our modern
thinking on just about every science in
the world come from? It's Greek
philosophy.
What about the iron? Do we have anything
to do with Roman
teachings? Absolutely. Our entire
judicial system is based on Roman
thinking which has incorporated all
those others and the feet of iron and
clay. They are just the heirs of a
system gone before. The wind swept them
away without leaving a trace. This is
very important. Wind is a symbol of war.
War will this final war will totally
destroy the kingdoms of earth. But the
rock that struck the statue became a
huge mountain. Mountain is a symbol in
the Bible of a kingdom
and filled how much of the earth? The
whole earth. There won't be different
nations anymore like we have today. So
if you have your hopes on any one of
them, forget it. This this prophecy says
no. Daniel 2:35,
Isaiah 65:17, for behold, I create a new
heaven and a new earth, and the former
shall not be remembered or come to mind.
And then he interprets the dream. Thou,
oh king, and he was the king of Babylon.
He stood for Babylon. art king of kings.
Very interesting nuance here in the
Bible. Lowerase K, lowerase K. Wow.
There's another king of kings who is
uppercase K,
lowerase K. Who's that?
That's Jesus. He's King of Kings and
Lord of Lords. Here's another one that
calls himself King of Kings. And he was
known as king of kings. He was the king
of kings, the ruler. Is there another
power today that has a title, an
official title, king of kings? The
answer is yes. There is a power today so
mighty, so invasive in the world
that it would surprise us. And the title
that it bears is king of kings.
Babylonian philosophy living today. For
the God of heaven has given thee a
kingdom power and strength and glory.
You, oh king, are a king of kings,
lowercase K. You are this head of gold.
And after thee shall arise another what?
Kingdom inferior to thee. To thee.
Daniel 2:39.
So Babylon will fall and will be
replaced by another kingdom inferior.
Gold is a precious metal. Silver is a
less precious metal. But silver is
harder
than gold. So the ultimate philosophy of
a king of kings was in the head of gold.
The ultimate philosophy of Babl, another
portal to heaven, was in the gold. It
was strengthened in the next kingdom.
Although it became more brutal and less
refined,
its chest and arms of silver. There are
two components to a chest and to her
arm. And there will be two components to
the next kingdom as well. The whole
earth prostate at her feet. Babylon was
never to dissipate, was never to be
destroyed. Nebuchadnezzar thought he had
built up a kingdom that would never go
away. Here is an inscription that was
found sealed by a seal of Nebuchadnezzar
where it says, "May it last forever." He
could not conceive of a kingdom that
would be destroyed. But Daniel pointed
to him and he said to him, "The kingdom
will disappear. Your kingdom will
disappear." This proud ruler said,
"Whoa, whoa, never." And what did he do?
After he had humbled himself at first,
later on he hardened his heart and he
thought to himself, "Never. I will defy
the King of Kings.
My kingdom of gold will never be
destroyed. Never will it go to silver,
to bronze, to iron, to iron and clay.
Never. It'll stand forever. Build me a
statue, pure gold, head to foot." What
was he saying?
What was he saying when he was doing
that? He was defying the God of heaven.
He was saying, "I defy you. I will set
up my kingdom and you will not destroy
it." Is it possible that there is a
power today that is saying the same
thing? I defy you. I will set up a
kingdom and it will not be destroyed. Is
it possible? We'll see. It's more than
possible. It's more than possible. It's
a sad reality in the world we're living
to today. So this king might have been
arrogant at that stage, but there's an
equally arrogant power today doing the
same thing.
Daniel 3:16 to18 Shadrach Mishak Abnego
replied to the king, O Nebuchadnezzar,
we do not need to defend ourselves
before you in this matter. If we are
thrown into the blazing furnace, the God
we serve is able to save us from it. And
he will rescue us from your hand, O
king. But even if he does not, we want
you to know, oh king, that we will not
serve your gods or worship the image of
gold you have set up. So he called
everyone, including the Hebrews, who had
interpreted this vision for him and
said, "Bow down. When you hear the sound
of the music and the horn and the sitter
and the liar and all kinds of music, bow
down."
Is music an instrument used today to get
nations together? Yes or no?
Is it? Wow. It surely is.
So these three said, "We will not bow
down." And even if he does not help us,
we will not bow down. Who else says
that? Job said that. Job had that kind
of faith. Job said, "Even if he slay me,
yet will I serve him." Wow, that's
great. So they were thrown into the
fiery furnace. And what happens?
The cords burn away. The soldiers that
throw them in are burnt to death. And
Daniel 3:26, Nebuchadnezzar then
approached the opening of the blazing
furnace and shouted, "Shadrach, Meshach,
Abnego, servants of the most high God,
come out, come here." Because when he
looked in, he saw a forth amongst them
who looked King James version like the
son of God.
other virgin v vers virgins who looked
like a son of the gods.
Big difference between the two.
Daniel 3:28 and Nebuchadnezzar said,
"Praise be to the God of Shadrach,
Meshach and Abetgo, who has sent his
angel and rescued his servants. They
trusted in him and defied the king's
command and were willing to give up
their lives rather than serve or worship
any god except their own god." So the
Torah story tells us that Nebuchadnezzar
was humbled. Did you know that
Nebuchadnezzar is the only heathen king
who has the privilege of writing a
chapter in the Bible? Wow. He got to
write a chapter in the Bible. The story
of his conversion. Read it in the book
of Daniel. And Nebuchadnezzar, I
believe, will be in heaven one day
because he was converted. His pride was
humbled. But this is what it looked
like. It was a magnificent city. Here is
the emblem of Babylon the lion. Hanging
gardens. He built this for his wife Amua
who longed for mountains. And here was a
flat area. She was not very happy. So he
said to her, "I'll build you a
mountain." And he built it for her.
Those were kings in those days. They had
power. Here is the famous Ishtar gate
which you can still find in the Pergamum
Museum. Beautiful reliefs of the
original stones, uniform writings that
have been dug up tell the story of
Nebuchadnezzar.
These portals for the astonishment of
multitudes of people whose beauty I
adorned
for the astonishment of men I have built
this house.
Nabonides.
Now who was Nabonidus? He was the
father. and to Bal Sasha, the exalted
son, the offering of my body, the father
of who? Balshasa. Isn't that
interesting? You see, the higher critics
here had some fun again. The Bible talks
about the final king of Babylon being
Belshasa.
And uh the critics said, "No, no, he
wasn't king. Nabonidus was king." But
what they didn't realize, not having the
ununiform writings to decipher at that
stage, was that Nabonidus had withdrawn
himself into religious service. He was a
highly religious man and he served in
the Babylonian priesthood and he gave
the rulership to his son. So this was an
inscription that was found. And to
Belshasa, the exalted son, the offering
of my body, do thou place the adoration
of the great deity in his heart. may not
give way to sin, may be satisfied with
life's abundance, and may reverence for
the great divinity dwell in his heart of
Belshasa, my firstborn favorite son. God
speaks to modern man, page 154, Bible
vindicated. In 1882, an inscription was
found confirming that Nabonidas had left
the kingship to his son. In 1916, an
inscription was found in which there was
a joint oath of Balsasa and Nabonidas.
There again, the higher critics blew it.
The Bible was proved right. 1924, they
found the famous inscription, I
conferred kingship to my son, Belshasa.
Bite the dust, higher critics. Bible
wins. Round one for them. Nothing for
the for the enemies of that. And then
the writing appeared upon the wall. And
we hear the story of the old prophet
Daniel being called in to interpret the
writing on the wall. Many God has
numbered your kingdom Belchasa and
finished it.
Tech you have been weighed in the
balances and found wanting and Perez
your kingdom has been divided and given
to the Mes and the Persians. Very
interesting. two arms, me and Persians.
And the prophet interprets a writing
written by a finger against the wall. Do
you know that in the Bible there are
only four times
when God writes with his finger?
First time he writes the ten
commandments with his finger. The Bible
says he wrote them on two tablets of
stone.
Then Moses smashed them when he came
down and found the the Israelites in
idolatry. And then he hewed new stones.
And again, God wrote with his finger
what he had written on the first one.
And then here in Babylon at the fall of
Babylon, God wrote with his finger. So
God wanted to make very sure that
everybody realized that he will bring
Babylon to an end. He wrote it with his
finger. And at the end, the Bible says
there is another kind of Babylon in the
book of Revelation which will come to an
end just as surely. And what's the
fourth time when God wrote with his
finger?
Jesus wrote with his finger in the sand.
Interesting. That's the only record we
have of Jesus writing something with his
finger.
Unwilling Babylon. Jeremiah 51:9. We
would have healed Babylon, but she
cannot be healed. Revelation 2:21, I
have given her time to repent of her
immortality,
but she is unwilling. There is ancient
Babylon. There's modern Babylon. Who is
this modern Babylon?
Bible names Cyrus
150 years before his birth. The prophet
Isaiah in chapter 45 says, "Thus says
the Lord to his anointed to Cyrus, whose
right hand I've holden to subdue nations
before him, and I will loose the loins
of kings to open before him the twoleaf
gates, and the gates shall not be shut."
The Bible predicts this King Cyrus would
come, and he would set free. The Bible
calls him the anointed one. Do you know
that the Bible uses this terminology for
Cyrus and it uses it for Jesus? So this
heathen king here who brings to an end
Babylon is used as a typology
of the great king who will come and
bring an end to final Babylon. Very
interesting analogy. Very interesting.
Cyrus cylinder with the whole story in
ununiform writing of how it happened. I
am Cyrus, king of the world, the great
and just king, king of Babylon, king of
Sumer and Akad, king of the four corners
of the world, son of Gambesas. When I
stepped into Babylon as a friend and
descended the throne amidst cheers of
joy and pageantry in the governor's
palace, my countless soldiers roamed
Babylon in peace and sincerity. I
forbade harassment and terror all over
Sumer and Akad. I strove for peace in
Babylon in all other cities. I abolished
forced labor in respect with citizens of
Babylon which was against their social
status. I helped restore destroyed
houses. I accommodated them again with
with a peaceful place. Ducks and doves I
tried to preserve their habitats. See,
God is going to restore all things as
well. The army marched in under the
gates of Babylon. They had been left
open. The river was diverted because God
changes times and seasons and removes
kings and sets up kings. And it's he who
gives wisdom unto the wise and knowledge
to them that know not understanding.
That brought to an end the Babylonian
kingdom. And now the next kingdom is to
come. We will do that in another
session.
539 BC to 331
BC the next kingdom to rule the earth
the Meo Persians came to follow on after
Babylon.
In Daniel chapter 2:39, we read about
this kingdom. Then another kingdom, a
third kingdom of bronze will ar shall
rule over all the earth. That's the next
one to come.
I am persuaded that there was no nation,
city, nor people where his name did not
reach. There seems to me to have been
some divine hand presiding both over his
birth and actions. Historical library,
book 16, chapter 12. So the Bible
describes the rise of the Meo Persian
Empire and its fall to this mighty king
Alexander the Great who would destroy
this army. Do you know that Alexander
destroyed the Meo Persian armor army
with an army of only 45,000 soldiers and
the Meo Persians had an army of 1
million soldiers. He flattened them. He
was a great strategist and knew exactly
what he was about. So the Greek Empire
followed upon the Meoersian Empire. The
Meopersian Empire contributed to the
religion of Babylon. It took the
religion of Babylon, refined it in the
Mitraic system, which it handed over to
the next generation and Mitraism then
resurfaces later as a prominent insider
religion of the elite of Rome. Very
interesting story. But the Greek
philosophy was the great foundation
stone for many many philosophies in the
world today. So Greeks follows on the
Meo Persian Empire. Finally after the
Greek Empire Daniel 2:40 there will be a
fourth kingdom strong as iron.
Now if we look at the soldiers as they
were in the ancient days, Greece and
Rome are a very interesting comparison.
Here is the armory of the Greek
soldiers. Notice that it's bronze. That
was their armor. They used bronze. And
then came the Roman soldier. Here's a
Roman legionnaire. And what was their
armor?
Iron. Isn't that interesting? So even
this symbolism is fascinating. So we
switch from bronze to iron. And the
legionnaire had a fantastic armory. had
this little belt here in the front to
protect and this shield that protected
even the should soldiers uh the
shoulders of the soldiers. I have to
watch my S's here and uh this short
stubby sword. They were a tremendous
force and of course the power of Rome
was unparallel.
Iron is harder than bronze. Rome was
mightier in its power than the Greeks
were. Here are some of the ruins of the
Roman Empire. The fourth kingdom shall
be strong as iron. For as much as iron
breakth in pieces and subdues all
things, and as iron that breakth all
these shall it break in pieces and
bruise. Daniel 2:40. So this is a cruel
kingdom. Were the Romans particularly
cruel? What did they do to anyone that
dissented? What happened to them? They
crucified them. That was pretty harsh.
At the fall of Jerusalem, for miles
there were just crucifixes. Crucifixes.
Everybody was just crucified. You didn't
mess with Rome.
On June 22, 168 BC at the battle of
Pidna. Pus king of Macedonia was
completely crushed by the armies of
Rome. On this day perished the empire of
Alexander the Great. Yeah.
144 years after his death. So there it
perished. So the famous historian Edward
Gibbons says the images of gold, silver,
brass that might serve to represent the
nations and their kings were
successively broken by the iron monarchy
of Rome. The history and decline and
fall of the Roman Empire. The whole
world agrees that iron was the kingdom
of Rome.
In the second century, Hippolitus wrote
of Rome, "Rejoice, blessed Daniel, thou
hast not been in error, already the iron
rules." Did you know that when Alexander
the Great marched into Jerusalem, the
scribes marched towards him with the
Torah and said to him, "You will rule."
Daniel said, "You will conquer." And
because of that, Alexander did not
destroy Jerusalem, but just incorporated
them. The Bible says ahead of time who
would rule. Now, many a critic has come
up and said, "Oh, but surely Daniel must
have lived after the events." The Bible
is wrong. You know that the Bible has
been vindicated on that score because
the Dead Sea Scrolls
have portions of the book of Daniel
where it changes from Aramaic
to Hebrew. That little piece is there.
And when they study the Aramaic, which
they said was late Aramaic, oops, what
did they find in the Dead Sea Scrolls?
That it was Meo Persian Aramaic. So the
book of Daniel is authenticated from
that time
right up until
all these events are described. So it
was written all ahead of time. You
cannot mess with the Bible. You cannot
mess with it. So this mighty power Rome
came to destroy. Historian Charles
Rollins says they the Romans seized
discrim indiscriminately all provinces
and kingdoms and extended their empire
of all nations. In a word, they pres
prescribed no other limits to their vast
projects than those which deserts and
seas made it impossible to pass. Ancient
history volume 479.
So from 168 BC to 476 AD, Rome, the iron
monarchy ruled supreme. Now there were
two legs of iron. That's interesting.
Rome was split into two halves. the
eastern empire and the western empire
and the emperor for many years after
Constantine ruled from the eastern
bzantine empire. He ruled the whole
kingdom
but western Rome followed another path.
Very interesting story that we have just
as you saw says Daniel 2:41
that the feet and toes were partly of
baked clay and partly of iron. So are
there elements of Rome in the feet and
in the toes? Yes or no? Absolutely still
there. The iron is still there. The iron
isn't gone. So this will be a divided
kingdom.
Is the world trying to restore the Holy
Roman Empire? Yes or no?
What is the unification of Europe all
about?
Have you thought about that?
So, this will be a divided kingdom.
Daniel 2:42, as the toes were partly
iron and partly clay, so this kingdom
will be partly strong, partly brittle.
Has history proved that the nations of
Europe were sometimes strong and
sometimes weak and sometimes one ruled
and sometimes another? Wasn't Germany
mighty and France mighty and Britain
mighty? Yes or no? Didn't the Danes rule
for a while, etc., etc., etc.? Wasn't
the Austrian Empire mighty at one stage
with its kingdom? Absolutely.
So history has proved that right.
Jeremiah 18:6, like clay in the hand of
the potter, so are you in my hand, oh
house of Israel. These kingdoms might be
arrogant,
but uh they would be replaced.
They would be divided
and they would be divided into 10.
That's what the Bible says. There would
be 10 toes that would come forth. Now
these 10 toes are very interesting.
Where do these 10 toes arise? In the
western empire or in the eastern empire?
Very important question. And the Bible
tells us quite plainly that they arise
in the western empire and that the
western empire would exert an influence
over the entire world.
Does the Western Empire exert its
influence over the entire world? Yes or
no?
Absolutely. It is European
knowledge and wisdom that was
transported to the entire world. It was
Europeans
that conquered South America. It is from
the western European nations that the
United States and Canada and all its
components was incorporated into that
wisdom, that philosophy. It is western
ideology which comes from European stock
which is controlling world events. The
superpowers today have all can all trace
their roots to Western Europe.
So who were these Anglo-Saxons and
Franks and Alammani and Lombbo and
Ostrogoths and Nuruli and Beandians and
Visigoths and Svian Vandals? Who were
they?
So this is the division of the Western
Roman Empire. And notice that there is a
very interesting nation over here which
is known as the Ostrogoths.
And then there is another nation over
here which is known as the Vizigoths.
They were the beandians and they were
the Franks
and uh the Anglo-Saxons.
And the Franks and the Romans had a very
strong alliance at one stage. The
Ostrogoths and the Visigoths
they had a slightly different religion
to the rest of Europe and there were
many many many many wars that were
fought over this issue. So the Almani
today are the Germans. The Germans are
the remnant of the Alammani. The Swiss,
the Beagandians, the French, the Franks,
the Italians, the Lombards, the English,
the Saxons, the Portuguese, the Svi, the
Spanish, the Visigoths. But three of
them, the Heruli, the Vandals, and the
Ostrogoths are extinct. They're gone.
They have been wiped out.
The Ostrogoths, the last ones to be
wiped out, a mighty, mighty nation that
controlled all events in Rome. They
ruled over Rome itself.
The Visigoths
were in Spain and they had a slightly
different religion. There were many,
many, many wars fought in Spain. Spain
was divided, terribly divided into a
northern and a southern half and
terrible bloodshed was found in Spain.
But the Heruli and the Vandals and the
Ostrogoths were totally destroyed.
History tries to tell us that these
three were destroyed because they had a
Aryan philosophy which means they
propagated the idea that Christ did not
have divinity
and that they were therefore destroyed.
But we only have information from one
source. All their writings, everything
that they wrote has been destroyed. All
their libraries have been destroyed. So
we don't really know what they believe.
In actual fact, the Ostrogoths
probably received their religion from
Palestine and had a very pure form of
Christianity based on the Bible. And
that is why they were destroyed. But I
haven't got time to go into that. That
would be a whole lecture, a few lectures
all by itself. So let's concentrate on
this prophecy.
And wherest thou sourest iron mixed with
my clay, they shall mingle themselves
with the seed of men. So originally when
Rome fell, it was divided into 10. Three
of them were eventually destroyed. Today
we have the remnants. And they would mix
themselves with the seed of men. They
would try to reunite it by
intermarriage,
but they shall not cleave one to
another, even as iron is not mixed with
clay. Daniel 2:43.
So we had the great kings of Europe
trying to unite Europe through marriage.
And so we have Queen Diana and King
Frederick trying their utmost to bring
the nations together. Here's Frederick's
boy castle in Denmark from where the the
uh famous kings and queens ruled. Daniel
2:43. Where else they saw iron mixed
with my clay, they shall mingle
themselves with the seas of men. They
shall not cleave one to another, even as
iron is not mixed with clay. There you
have the famous Queen Victoria and King
Christian. Did you know that Queen
Victoria was
totally unenglish?
Did you know that she was German? Did
you know that she even spoke German on
her deathbed? When she was dying, her
mother tongue came back. She was a
German queen.
and King Christian of Denmark and her
offspring mingled with the seeds of men.
All the nations united. They were all
together.
So, different kings tried to reunite the
kingdoms. Here you have the pope
crowning Charles the Great, Charlemagne,
king of the Holy Roman Empire because
supposedly he had managed to reunite
Europe. And as that crown went onto his
head, the kingdom fell apart and
divided. So for a brief moment, they'd
come together again and then they fell
apart. And so the Charles's and the
Louies
and all these kingdoms of the earth and
the great kingdoms tried to reunite
Europe. And then came this Frenchman
Napoleon Bonaparte.
His brother was the grandmaster of
Freemasonry in Spain. Very interesting.
He was the grandmaster.
And all of these had insider
connections. And he wanted to reunite
Europe. And at the battle of Waterloo,
well, he met his Waterloo. Very
interesting history. We'll be talking
about this in some more detail because
everything we hear is not necessarily
what is true.
Here Napoleon is taken into exile.
Napoleon said, "I wanted to found a
European system, a European code of
laws, a European Court of Appeals.
There would have been but one people
throughout Europe. Europe would soon
have become one nation." The Watchmen,
1941.
He tried to reunite it
30 years after Waterloo. Dr. Thomas
Arnold said the deliverance of Europe
from the dominion of Napoleon was
affected neither by Russia nor by
Germany nor by England but by the hand
of God.
What was the principal adversary of this
tremendous power? By whom was it checked
and resisted and put down? By none and
by nothing but the direct and manifest
interposition of God. lectures on modern
history lecture three. It's very
interesting. Napoleon had very heavy
artillery and he would have outgunned
the much lighter artillery of the
British for example. But on that day
suddenly a fine rain fell and all his
heavy artillery became bogged down in
the mud and they couldn't move it. And
so the lighter, more mobile artillery of
the other forces
was just what was needed to blow them to
smitherines. So who won the battle? The
weather or the artillery?
It's interesting that some great
politicians in the past have said
history is on the side of the greatest
artillery, the heaviest artillery.
But there is a God in heaven that reveal
ath secret and makes known to the king
Nebuchadnezzar what shall be in the
latter days. This is an interesting
verse. Daniel 2:28, the latter days.
Well, if you read your Bible, if you
read Luke and Matthew 24, Luke chapter
21, you will see the events as they
unfold.
how one kingdom after the other will
make war and the very final events will
be nation against nation, kingdom
against kingdom, wars, famines, all
kinds of things, hearts failing for
fear. That's what the Bible says. And
the next event will be, says the Matthew
24 and Luke 21, the coming of Christ in
glory, the stone that will bring an end
to all the earthly kingdoms.
This was Kaiser Villhan. He tried to
bring an end to the division. And here's
a very interesting true story. At a
cathedral in France in Mets, there's a
statue outside the cathedral. This
statue over here of the prophet Daniel
with his finger pointing to his scroll.
Very interesting prophets uh prophet
here. And Kaiser Vilhelm, he was very
concerned about this statue. And then
one day the cathedral needed repair. The
roof had become uh
it fell apart and it had to be replaced.
And so they asked Kaiser for the money
to repair the cathedral. And Kaiser said
the following. He said, "You have a
statue in front of your cathedral of
Daniel." So obviously he knew what
Daniel said and obviously he was annoyed
by the prophecy. So he said, "I will
give you the money to repair your
cathedral if you remove his head." Now
remember these statues are in sections
and put my head on top of the statue.
Do you think they did it? This is
history. You can check it out. Do you
think they did it? Yes, they did it.
They did it. And they put the head of
the original Daniel into the archives
and he replaced the roof. And so for a
while, Ka Villam's head was on the
statue. What was he trying to say?
He was like Nebuchadnezzar of old. He
was saying, "I don't care what your
prophet said. I will do it." Isn't that
what he was saying? I don't care what
your prophet said. I will do it. A
fascinating history. Well, here he is
dead. But this is not him. This is his
dog.
His dog accompanied the Kaiser during
the First World War, 1914 to 1918.
And then eventually another would arise,
Daniel 2:21. And he changes times and
seasons and removes kings and sets up
kings. And if you Kaiser Vilham think
that you can put your head on the statue
of Daniel saying I will do it my way and
you God will not have any influence of
it. You'll be dead and it won't work.
And there was the next one. Now here's a
fascinating story. Here was another man.
Do you think he understood the
prophecies of Daniel? Do you think he
was interested?
Adolf Hitler was interested in the
occult world like no other before him.
There were two who were highly
interested in the occult world. The one
was
Napoleon.
Napoleon in fact sent his whole one of
his whole army cores to Egypt to go and
find out the source of the power of the
pharaoh that threw his staff and it
turned into snakes. Did you know that?
And it is the French who discovered what
in
Egypt?
the Rosetta Stone from which all the
hieroglyphics have been unfathommed.
Isn't that an amazing story? And they
studied the secrets of the power of the
Egyptians. And in the occult world,
this knowledge is incorporated
in the hermetic books. They studied the
origin of Ham, Hermes, son of her, son
of Ham, and the occult knowledge and
they compiled huge volumes on the
history of Egypt.
This man over here was an occultist of
the highest order. He was an insider
initiate in the occultism. Did you know
that the entire SS was built up on
occult principles? Did you know that?
And isn't it interesting that he sent an
entire division to where?
To Egypt and that the German
archaeologists were the one who did the
great digs under the protection of Raml.
And there the insider knowledge was
gathered of the occult principles which
dictate many a king and ruler. Today
we're going to talk about some very
interesting things in this series. Adolf
Hitler knew about the prophecy of
Daniel. How do we know?
He gave an interesting instruction.
He contacted the cathedral at Mets and
said, "Remember that you have Kaiser
Villain's head on that statue? Take it
off.
Put the head of Daniel back." What was
he saying?
What was he saying?
Daniel's head went back onto the statue.
He was saying, "With or without that
head, I'll do it." Wow. Fascinating
stuff. History is more interesting than
we believe. Really, it is. If you make
an in a study of the occult world and
how it has influenced
our great political leaders in the past,
you'll be surprised.
And here Adolf Hitler came. And here is
the symbol that is used the swastika
which is the symbol of sun worship. It's
the symbol of Lucifer. It is used by
theosophy society which says Lucifer is
the logos the serpent the savior.
Exactly the same symbol is used by
theosophy and theosophy is it dead? Oh
no. Theosophy is alive and well and
forms the central theme
of the greatest powers that rule the
world today.
And we will revealing some of these
things in the lectures to come. This is
interesting stuff. The eagle used as the
symbol of deity. You see the Bible uses
the eagle as the symbol of God. Like an
eagle that rises up, I will take you
under my wings.
That is the symbol of God. Lucifer wants
to be like the most high. He takes the
symbol of the eagle which was a symbol
in Egypt of Horus.
Fascinating.
There it is. The eagle with a swastika.
And the swastika can be left-handed
swastika or a right-handed swastika. If
it is the left-handed or the
right-handed, it makes no difference. It
represents the god in his evil and in
his light form or in his male or in his
female form. It doesn't matter which one
you use. Secret societies today use the
very one in the mirror image today and
say, "But it's something else." It's not
something else. Buddhism uses that
symbol. Buddhism, the foot of Buddha has
swastikas under every single toe. It's
just the reverse one. Makes no
difference. It's just the other six of
the deity that is being on it. So what
is happening here to the world? Is there
an agenda behind the scenes? What is
this circle and this swastika really
mean
regarding the first world war? Winston
Churchill said after the end of the
World War of 1914, "Was Winston
Churchill a member of a secret
fraternity?" Yes or no? Yes, he was.
Isn't that fascinating? Was Stalin a
member of a secret fraternity? Yes or
no? Yes, he was.
Well, maybe history is not as boring as
you thought, young guys. Isn't that so?
I always thought history was boring when
I was a kid, but today I find it
fascinating. Putting the pieces
together. Wow. Regarding the first world
war, Winston Churchill said, "After the
end of the world war of 1914, there was
a deep conviction and almost universal
hope that peace would reign in the
world." The gathering storm, page three.
After the first world war, that's
interesting.
Well, did any of these great rulers,
whether it was the Kaiser Villains or
the Napoleons or the Louisis or the
Charles's or the Hitlers, did they
succeed?
No. Europe was more divided after the
war than before the war. Ah, but that
division was deceptive as we will see.
And then the walls came down
and empires started crumbling.
And the great people of the world, the
Lenins and the Stalines that had
murdered their millions for very
clandestine reasons. Suddenly these
empires crumbled. The Maallen the wall
must fall. All of these great leaders
from Lewa
to this lady over here Thatcher to
Kushchoff and Gorbachof and the queens.
Do they belong to secret orders? Do
they? Who's the head of the
Bilderberers? Who's the queen of the
Bilderberggers?
Yes, she is. That's very interesting.
Is there such a thing as a Gorbachof
Foundation with its seat in New York?
Yes, there is very interesting things.
And then the founder of the KGB comes
down.
A symbol falls. Does it really fall?
Does it really fall? Who rules
in Russia today? Who is the head of
Russia today?
Putin. What was he? He was the head of
the KGB. You see? Isn't that
interesting? So they take down a symbol
and the people think the oppression is
gone. When the oppression is not gone at
all, it's just taken another robe. It's
like a chameleon changes color, but the
essence it doesn't change. And the God
of heaven, is he watching? Yes, the God
of heaven is watching. He told us ahead
of time it would happen. And he told us
in great detail, Soviet Union no longer
exists. Three republics unite. Gorbachof
obsolete. Bush needs recovery time. Blah
blah blah. Reading Europe's future. Can
we all get along? In the hands of the
people.
It's more than money. Monetary Union.
Sea of troubles. A currency storms blows
European unity off course. Leland Stow
said, "Humanity has been given a
suspended sentence, but its days of
grace are fearfully short. While time
remains, page 343.
The God of heaven will set up a kingdom
which shall never be destroyed.
It shall break in pieces and consume all
these kingdoms and it shall stand
forever. Now I want you to think
seriously tonight all those who are here
present. Is the world preaching that we
are heading towards a kingdom of peace?
Yes or no? Yes, but it will be a worldly
kingdom. Where do they want to set up a
final kingdom of peace? Up there
somewhere in Jerusalem. Are they
fighting about it? What does God say? He
will bring to an end what? How many of
the kingdoms on this earth? All of them.
That's what God says. All of them. And
he will set up a kingdom. Do you think
he needs the armies of the world to do
it for him?
Everyone who falls on that stone will be
broken to pieces, but he on whom it
falls will be crushed. That's what the
Bible says. For he will wipe every tear
from their eyes. There will be no more
death or mourning or crying or pain. For
the old order of things has what? Passed
away. Revelation 21:4. We must not be
deceived into believing
that the powers on this earth are going
to achieve the objective that they're
fighting for. They will not achieve it.
It will be brought to an end. They will
appear
to achieve it. How do we know that?
Because the Bible says when they say
peace,
peace, when will the nations on earth
say that? When they appear to have
obtained their objective. Isn't that
right? What does the Bible say? What
will happen then?
Sudden destruction.
And who will that destruction come from?
It will come from God. And why would the
God of heaven have to intervene to
destroy that final unity? Why would he
have to do that? Because it is an occult
unity.
It is a unity against God. It is an
anti-christos
unity.
Scary stuff.
The world is terribly deceived today. We
need to study these prophecies carefully
and unfold them and unravel them and to
see the finer nuances so that we cannot
be deceived when a preacher stands up
and says the antichrist lived in the
past. He was a Greek king. His name was
Antiocus Epipanus 4, but he was
destroyed by the rock.
Hello.
The rock struck the feet. Didn't strike
the hips. didn't strike a Greek king.
Daniel chapter 8, Daniel chapter 9.
Be careful how we interpret the
prophecy. We cannot have a wrong spin on
this ball. Christ will return the rock
of all ages. Verse 35. And the stone
that smoked the image became a great
mountain, a mountain in the Bible, a
kingdom, and filled the whole earth. God
himself is going to set up a kingdom.
The dream is certain
and the interpretation thereof is sure.
Daniel 2:45. Now, we've had very little
detail tonight, but we've had a pretty
accurate sweep through history. And
would you agree that Daniel was just
spoton? Yes or no? Absolutely. Daniel
was spot on. Now, I have sad news for
you. Terribly sad news for you. Daniel
is going to take the picture. Tonight's
picture was like a picture you give to a
child to color in. It's just the
outline.
And then you give the child the crayons
and you say, "Color in the picture."
Now, in our next lecture, we'll do
Daniel chapter 7 and we're going to
color in the picture and then it gets
scary.
Because then we will see who the real
power is. And some of us will be hurt.
Some of us will be shocked. Some of us
may say, "I never want to hear any more
of this." But I would encourage you to
keep on coming because there is a
fascinating solution to this. Did you
know that the book of Revelation takes
this final great battle between good and
evil, which is a secret battle? It's a
secret battle. The very first words
Jesus uses when asked what is the sign
of your coming and the end of the age.
The very first thing he says is be
careful lest anyone
deceive you.
Deception is the name of the game. Are
there wolves in sheep's clothing
deceiving God's people?
Is the world being led down some garden
path faithfully following thinking they
are doing something good when they are
being led into the pits of hell. Is it
possible
if we believe the prophets and if we
study them carefully and even if it
hurts and believe you me
I've stood on the other side of the
fence
and when I studied the prophecy I was
hurt and my family was hurt and there
were buckets of tears
but now I have buckets of hope
buckets of hope because God has shown me
and has shown everybody in the world
through his word and that's the only
place where we can find it that there is
hope. But he has also outlined the
entire deception of our time and we need
to know. There's a very small crowd here
tonight. Very small crowd. The whole
world needs to know what the deception
is. So, I would like to encourage you to
bring your friends and call them off the
streets. Go to the highways. Go to the
byways. Invite people to the wedding
feast of the lamb. Not many rich, not
many wise, not many of high repute will
listen to you. But go into the highways
and byways and bring them here. And
let's look at the prophecies. And I make
a vow to you. If I speak anything that
is contrary to the word of God,
leave.
Leave. If it doesn't say so, leave. Test
every word I say. Put it into the checks
and balances. Use the word of God as
your filter. And if you can show me that
I'm wrong, I'll change. I promise. I
don't want to do anything that's not in
line with God's will. That's my
challenge. We will stick to the word of
God and we will see exactly what's
happening in our time. It's scarier than
you think, but we have hope because the
God of heaven will set up a kingdom
which will never be destroyed. And we're
right in front of the door. And I for
one would like you all to be part of
that kingdom. May God bless you and keep
you until we come together for the
coloring in episode of Daniel chapter 7.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
I don't
know.